megan fox and machine gun kelly's big
apple date night rachel smith was there
and joins us from madame tussauds new
york in times square those two
love a twinning moment rage
oh you know they do michelle and while
it was mgk's big premiere megan was the
one calling the chats
[Applause]
[Music]
look at you in your crop top yeah yeah
it's pink your favorite color it's my
daughter's favorite color i think she
probably inspired that in me and now
machine gun kelly's 12 year old daughter
casey is taking center stage in his new
hulu dock life in pink streaming now i
feel like people have to dig deeper than
just like what they see on the internet
casey is such a bright young lady she
stole the dog to me no i gotta say i did
hear you say in the documentary you call
megan your wife a beautiful thing that
we get to go and share this with the
world with my wife i'm with my best
friend when did that happen it never
felt right calling on my girlfriend
girlfriend seems too adolescent for the
like the depth of our relationship
are you so proud of this young man right
here i am i'm super proud i do believe
you told me at the vmas what daddy wants
daddy
i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says
it was like the most memorable line i do
believe i've ever received in an
interview before thank you i'm good for
those i'm good for those sound bites
i'm curious do you guys have an official
wedding day
no he's on tour this year when it needs
to happen it'll open up the universe
will open it up and we'll do it
[Music]
well they may not be married yet as we
see in the dock the couple of more than
two years have already been through
thick and thin he went through a very
difficult time when he considered taking
his own life megan went to bulgaria to
shoot a movie i called megan i was like
you aren't here for me i put the shotgun
in my mouth
and i go to [ __ ] the shotgun and the
shell just gets jammed megan's like dead
silent
you were on the receiving end of that
phone call how the two of you healed and
grown together we've done every form of
therapy that exists
it's a constant process of like
suffering
and passion and love and the repeat
cycles and there's lots of all of those
things all of the time